okay so uh ask questions wherever okay
um just start talking if I'm not looking
at you okay
so your
iido is not going to
violate uh certain sciences that we know
okay even though there's a mystical
aspect to it remember
Mystic does not refer to the way modern
culture we don't refer to that okay um
Mystic comes from the word mystery
mystery is
associated uh with religious activity
that Scholars look back at the uh high
points in the Greek age and certain
religious practices that we now call
religious um were Mystic and we we call
them M Mystic for because those Cults
were called mystery Cults okay and their
cult is not referred to in the modern
pejorative sense of the word as some
crazy uh tradition separate from the
world's major religions okay when
Scholars of religion look back uh
Catholicism has is cultic it's just what
you refer to those practices so these
mystery Cults um were called that
because you had to belong to them there
was an initiation process that you had
to go through and if you weren't
initiated you did not see the
practices um today the secular world has
made that suspect but if you pay
attention um there's a lot of stuff here
that I just don't tell beginners because
they just have no reference for it um uh
there's no way you can explain to them a
lot of things that are going on so you
just get them in the ballpark with
things like uh you know here's how you
stand um here's how you stick your hand
out it's very mundane is very physical
um very superficial uh and and a certain
level of understanding is required
before things start to make sense to you
um have people over the centuries taken
advantage of the fact that you have
initiates and non- initiate yes yes they
have uh you see a lot of that in in um
in taiichi circles for example uh going
into into China as they're starting to
spread out you you have the original
practice look you need a certain base of
understanding to even get what I'm
talking about um but then you have other
people that are like selling initiation
and then they're just trying to make
money with okay but the idea that you
need to have a certain base before I can
explain more difficult things to you is
something you see every day we don't
talk to Children the way we talk to
adults and we don't talk to every adult
the same way right a certain level of
wisdom knowledge experience is necessary
that assumes the context in which
language takes place okay so it's really
no different so you had these mystery
calls they were initiation Cults you had
to be initiated and that word mystery uh
Scholars of religion have taken on to
apply to uh certain practices those
practices today called mystical
practices okay uh but they're not used
in the same way that we use it today in
a in a civilian sense or a popular sense
it means like woo woo or fake or stuff
like that
okay um
but there's certain assumptions that
when we talk about uh how to
move um and they have to be consistent
with uh all the other movement sciences
that we have you you're not going to woo
woo your way out of a physics
understanding of what is going on or a
biomechanical understanding of what is
going on or a kinesiological
understanding of what is going on so in
other words sound
iido uh is going to be sound with these
three major Sciences it's not going to
woo woo its way out of them it's not
going to say well inside a mystical
State the laws of physics are
transformed that's not going to happen
Okay um so while we do have a mystical
aspect to our practice here we also have
this aspect and usually this is where
most of your Corrections are coming from
your your your Kinesiology is off it's
wrong your biomechanics is off the
physics is off um and I would say uh
most of modern iido is not only void of
any legitimate mysticism by which it has
its spiritual aspects valid and viable
but it's also invalid k kinesiologic
biomechanically and physically is it's
wrong and what makes it look like it
works is the choreography okay so uh you
just like a stuntman with wires and
pulley can do amazing things but there
were wires and pulley to you see to make
something work well UK will get
themselves in positions out of
choreography and out of social pressure
to be a good UK which means to follow
the
choreography uh that these aikidoka are
surprised when their stuff does not work
against resisting subjects and things
like that okay why because it's
kinesiological unsound biomechanically
unsound Etc okay and that's where most
of your Corrections coming from on on
the mat that foots in the wrong place or
weights on the wrong uh ground path etc
etc okay um so there's things that we
want to
understand um because what whatever you
can
achieve by reconciling the two minds ego
tripartite mind and the god mind
whatever you can achieve it is never
going to violate these Sciences it's
it's not done okay so you have to have
these things which is why at the
beginning level we don't really talk
about the mystical practices we just get
your body in the right place okay and so
most of your Corrections come from that
all right um so some things that we want
to talk about is your your overall
um you know moving a body physically
through space any body moving through
space is it's going to move according to
our laws our physical laws that we
understand so gravity inertia momentum
Etc things like that okay uh and when
you apply that um to the human body uh
you're going to get into this field
which is kinesiology which is the study
of the body through uh in movement okay
uh and kinesi Kinesiology is a broader
scientific field of which biomechanics
is a subset okay so this is your your
body moving through space all right uh
and then but it will include things like
friction inertia Etc do see and then
biomechanics a subset of Kinesiology is
going to refer to your human body body
uh as it as it is something that is
movable so it's going to refer to your
muscles and your joints and things like
that on how a human body uh moves
through uh moves through space okay
that's what we're trying to look at and
some inry way understanding is just to
take because physics especially
theoretical physics gets way out there
um which is why you don't really want to
play out here too much although you got
to pay attention to what we're
discovering but you really do hang out
here a lot okay um because physics will
talk about things uh out in environments
different from wherein a human body is
functioning okay so for example we're
probably always on Earth with this
amount of gravitational pull Etc and
we're probably not in places that are
other than that okay so we're really
focusing here and when you do Focus here
uh a good place to start is just with
Newton's three laws um why do I draw
that distinction because out here these
things are not so Universal nor constant
okay but when you're in here and you're
dealing with uh human bodies on planet
Earth these things are still pretty
relevant
okay
um the key one that I want to pay
attention to so just just real quickly
though uh so something is going to stay
where it is or how it is this is the law
of con constancy so something's going to
stay how it is unless another force is
acting upon it so for example to apply
it to your kho Wen we'll just stick
there as ukas coming in with spinal
displacement UK should continue going
straight if left
alone uh a violation that you tend to
see of this law in uh iido is is UK will
start to turn into the kazushi pattern
that most kihon waza have uh so UK is
turning themselves okay um and when this
aikidoka goes into real life has someone
over penetrate uh and is expect and goes
ahead and does a turn and expecting them
to be there they either will keep going
they'll keep going straight and they
pass and they just miss the opportunity
you you see that constantly whenever
some aikidoka thinks he got to the back
uh and then tries to do like idag and
there's just no way there's too much
centrifugal energy on the continued
angle of attack okay you see that a
lot um the other one is mass times
acceleration equals force uh and the
idea is here really in your kihon waza
the most The more mass you have in your
Force levers the more Force you can
generate the more Force you can generate
the more resistance you could overcome
and here resistance is usually going to
be the mass of the UK okay so uh if you
have less Force you can't overcome
greater mass a larger UK do you see um
you're going to have to choreograph your
UK to move themselves which you see a
lot in modern iido uh and for those who
don't know what that is it's usually
what your high ranking uh UK who flip
over for their shans with the blink of
their eye all of a sudden are these
solid tree stumps on you because you
don't outrank them okay um you don't
have the force to overcome their Mass
because you don't usually you don't have
as much mass as you need to go ahead and
accelerate and overcome that resistance
okay and so usually this is solved by
culture and iido your UK is going to
move for you if you outrank them and if
you don't outrank them then they're
going to with you okay and then
this one is not well understood in iido
but and this is the main one to
understand is that uh you're going to
have an equal and opposite Force to
every Force you'll apply okay um and
this is where I I want to really focus
on uh because it becomes
important in an art like iido which is
spiral in its combat geometry okay so
we're we're trying to do circles okay uh
either shrinking circles or larger uh
enlarging circles we're we're not trying
to to hit things at at uh right angles
and things like that okay um I would put
before you that none of the Japanese
Arts do I think a lot of iido people
think will think that karate um or
shenji Kempo is like this linear thing
and I think they just don't practice
those arts and they don't realize okay I
think any art on the silk World culture
is going to use rotational Force okay um
and this comes in the play in rotational
force uh because every time you either
try to pull something in or make
something go out there's going to be a
uh opposite Vector across your
rotational torque um so for example let
me simplify
this if here is my
resistance and I'm going to try to make
it go on a
curve which affords me all kinds of
advantages so I'm going to make it go
like on a
curve at every degree of rotation there
is another line that's cutting right
across that line okay it's just doing it
incrementally okay
and this is why we here
move with a ground path that is singular
in its architecture we don't
use two what I wouldn't even call Ground
pass we don't use two uh Bas of supports
element because
eventually the equal and opposite line
is going to cut through the uh Shak
of that stance okay so let me get you
there and I'll explain this to you and
this is why for example a lot of your
techniques feel
weak uh more so in jiu waza than in Kona
because in
Kona your
saki uh is doing too much
choreography got it and then in
Gaza they don't know which technique
you're going to do and by default
they're a little late and now you feel
that equal and opposite energy against
your rotational torque and it's cutting
through your basis support taking off
balance and decreasing how much power
you can apply in the spiraling pattern
because it's going to start pulling you
off your base okay so let's first
understand uh a couple things here we
have uh angle
of
disturbance okay and we have base of
support all right so your Bas of support
is we'll say that we're on the Flat
Earth okay it's going to be your contact
points with the Earth so let's say
there's your foot here's your
leg your contact points with the Earth
so there's your other foot and your
other leg and then the area in between
them that is your basis support so it's
going to be my contact points well
that's not really working but you get
the point okay that whole area there is
my Bas of
support in your Bas of support you also
have something called your line of
gravity
and your line of
gravity is going to be a theoretical
line which means it's I can't physically
see
it from your Center gravity in this case
I'm standing up so my center of gravity
somewhere around my H perpendicular to
the
Earth so it's a theoretical line so
we'll draw it with with dots
okay
and as long as my line of gravity is
inside my Bas of support I'm in Balance
okay when my line of gravity is taken
outside of my Bas of support we have
another concept and that is angle of
disturbance okay in Japanese this is
kazushi okay so if I start to lean this
body over for
example okay and this dot here is your
center of
gravity and your line of gravity is a
perpendicular line from your center of
gravity to the Earth to the area between
your base of support okay as you start
to lean over your center of gravity is
going to start to raise and come out
here do you see and the line of gravity
will now
move because it's always
perpendicular and to get an angle of
disturbance I always have to take the
center of gravity and the line of
gravity outside the Bas of support So if
I can lean this guy over
enough
and the line of gravity the center of
gravity is over here and it's
perpendicular oh I'm right on the edge
okay when I get that outside entirely
out of the base of support the person
the UK only has two choices they have
they have to regain their balance by
moving their base of support back under
their line of gravity or they're going
to fall
okay so we want we want to understand
this now to move someone's center of
gravity up their body and their line of
gravity outside of their base of support
I as Naga have to apply Force because
nobody does that on their own except
aikidoka that don't have real iido okay
cuz the UK is going to do
it and every time I'm going to move this
Mass such that the center of gravity and
the line of gravity fall outside of the
base support I am going to be affected
by this third law I'm generating force
to move the center of gravity and the
line of gravity and I'm going to have
this equal and opposite force acting
upon my mass okay and so let me uh and
and this becomes more and more
complicated when your art is trying to
use a spiraling geometry to make it
happen Okay and here's here's again what
I said is
you're looking down at someone's feet
okay you're looking at the top I'm not
going to draw their body here's their
feet okay and imagine they're doing uh
EO and here is UK's arm which is a lever
okay and as they try to uh turn the UK
around there's always that equal an
opposite force acting on the mass that
they're moving okay so right now if if
UK's head is over here and their spines
over here this kind of works at this
point because the equal and opposite
line can be grounded on the inside foot
but at a certain point let's say in the
deeper into the
spiral where the arm is over over here
now and they're acting on this part that
equal and opposite Line is now falling
outside the Bas of support it's not
falling on the on the uh grounding foot
okay and this is actually an angle of
disturbance okay so I'm going to show
you these Concepts as we go through all
right here we go get everyone on the
same page I will okay so here
is the lever that I'm trying to move to
move his Center okay so if you look here
I'm going to apply force incrementally
on a rotation so you're going to pay
attention maybe CA come over here you
guys can stay in frame I want you to
understand what's going on so as I
rotate this and just walk with me as I
rotate this in a
circle physically I have Force at
various pie slices as we're going around
do you see that and so at this
point this foot is ground vectoring that
resistance point to move it through
space okay and that equal and opposite
energy as I push here there's the equal
and opposite energy coming back at the
exact angle that I'm pushing so right
now it's on the foot do you see it's on
that foot as I do it but as we start to
go
it starts to go in between my legs that
equal and opposite energy do you see and
that means now if you come over
here and you're going to be you're going
to you're going to represent that equal
and opposite energy do you got it and so
her equal and opposite energy is not
being ground vector and this is my angle
of disturbance between my feet so she
can easily push me over between my feet
feet you see you see that and that's
what we do all the time the UK is we
don't push into their Bas of support we
push between the contact points all the
time okay so but usually what happens
you can step out now is your UK goes
around the the soft part of the
technique do you see and then and then
you can go and you can do this stuff
okay unless they out right
here so he's going to he's going to put
that other foot over there and here he's
grounding on that foot okay so you're
going to represent the equal and
opposite energy you see and she can
you're going to ground on that foot this
fo don't move okay and then but as he
starts to turn look where her equal and
opposite energy is now pushing between
his feet you see that and so now you
push Virginia you push into and you're
going to lose lose his face
if he loses his bace then he loses his
rotational Integrity you you can't bring
me around so we're just demonstrating
that you'd be pushed over but if you
reverse the equal and opposite
energy okay and we'll show it again here
here we're fine but once you start
rotating then we're not going to be fine
you see that and I will now be the equal
and opposite energy and this is is where
your senior UK
goes because you can never get enough
Mass into the technique so without your
mass doesn't matter your acceleration
your force or your ability to overcome
the resistance goes down why does it
always look like it works because you
outrank your UK and they'll step
themselves into the next contact point
so watch again stay there stay there
there and then Virginia comes over look
at his elbow line he's back on his foot
you see that Sean got it and then what
you'll do is you'll drop your how much
you weigh um 180 180 you'll drop your
180 on my elbow and then I go
down got it so everyone knows if I get
my weight on I can generally overcome
your
ability um but everyone gets stalled at
that from this Pivot Point into the
middle of the Bas of support where the
angle disturbance is until you can get
your weight back onto the top of it and
regain the back Pivot Point okay the
back Bas of support um again though
let's say
uh we know for example once he goes off
of that Pivot Point just leave it on the
ground please in the rotation he's now
between his his two pivot Points and
that's the angle disturbance that we use
all the time okay as
nit all right and then what he's going
to as he Bridges from this and if I
could use you you see she's pushing into
his back foot so you are on your basic
support there's no angle disturbance
it's
this that that 45 until so you can get
me back on that foot again you see and
it's that 45 where your
simpai look at you cuz you you can't get
that all right now the Assumption though
is the following go even if you got me
back to that Pivot Point remember here's
where everyone puts their weight on the
elbow right go
ahead because I'm never off balance you
see that I am never off balance here's
the thing go
back what the choreograph you get is
going to
do uh kohai is going to move from one
contact Point negate the need
for the Bas of support right and then
they move back to your Bas of support so
the force line never cut through your
contact points you guys understand
that's what choreography does I go on
and I this part to here here again
you're legitimate okay now however since
I moved myself there I'm not really off
balance you get it so as he goes I'm
actually countering him which again he
could put all his weight on there and
he's never going to get me down never
okay you guys understand that so the C
graphy is hiding a lot of things um so
let's look at this angle of disturbance
a little bit more closely so angle
disturbance is any line that I use to
take your Center your line of gravity
outside your Bas of support so get in
any stance you want okay so here if I
push at this line his line of gravity
the theoretical line from his center of
gravity per perpendicular to the Earth
will never fall outside that Bas of
support right you see that okay but if I
come over
here this is going to push that line
outside okay and so we do that all the
time in our spiraling geometry okay um
and so that concept there that
scientific concept is what allows both
this Senpai UK to jam your Technique up
right and what requires kohai UK to step
through the problem area and also gives
you the root Awakening when you try e
for example on someone who does not want
to know okay does that make sense okay
so let me have you guys play around with
those Concepts all right you can stall
them you can move you can now stall them
because you have your balance Etc all
right let's
try so uh this is why we have that rule
no double pivoting if you double pivot
on a spiraling
rotating uh top down combat foot
maneuver geometry eventually the equal
and opposite energy is going to cut
through your base of support generating
an angle disturbance it will either
reduce your ability to put force on the
point of rotation Andor you'll be
totally overcome by the a person that's
resisting okay so the real problem here
is that I have a double it stance so I'm
double pivoting okay again that is
totally overlooked in contemporary iido
because of the choreography okay or uh
no one has a problem with the fact that
you're musling everyone cuz you're
you're like you know 280 and you're
going on some small person that's like
110 okay like you you should be if your
if that's your dojo you should be
going whatever you know like not
impressed okay um does that make sense
okay so what we're GNA do instead is
have a single Pivot Point you have to
have a single Pivot Point my other foot
is touching the ground but that's not
the part that is moving him so I'm not
here you see and I have that foot and
then through choreography I pass through
the angle disturbance line right here
and then try to get on top with some
Mash here okay
so the first element is you have to have
a single pivot point if I have to have a
single pivot point there is no reason
for my foot to be out there my foot can
be in here okay and this part is the
same way as here I can generate Force
Virginia if you don't
mind she's she's the equal an opposite
line you see and she's in that foot you
see that and if I only have a single PIV
Point throughout this technique it
doesn't matter where that other foot is
you see and so I can keep moving it's
always on that foot as I'm moving around
you get it
okay it's the double Pivot
Point this is now I can't I cannot go
any further this is where your Senai
will get you there
okay all right
so here this foot near so you never
tempt that okay and this now allows you
to always be ground vectoring into the
technique so the same way
here there's the equal and opposite
energy the same way she can't do
anything cuz you're in that foot you're
still in that foot do you see didn't
change anything for you and now as I
keep moving I'm always doing that so
here's her new uh equal opposite energy
come over here there you are and or
still in that foot it feels exactly the
same to you and as we rotate
again it feels exactly the same to you
you see okay and we just going
incrementally down as we're coming
around okay so we
go same foot she's pushing I
turn same foot you see feels the same
and I start rotating the
arm feels the same till he's down
okay one thing you'll
notice on the other one where I go let
me just do it please we know it doesn't
work but let me do it okay I do you see
this but he can actually step his foot
on the other one where I am matching
equal and oppos energy that foot gets
pinned you see he doesn't do that
choreography step the foot's getting
pinned and now his center of gravity is
traveling up his body which makes the
line of gravity come outside his base
and support it's almost on the edge it's
like right here you get it and so now I
go and he falls outside of that base
guys see that all right let's try
it if if uh just let me make a side note
if your UK did take that step in it's
it's possible you can get under these
pressure lines right and all you're
going to do is on the wherever they land
you repeat the same geometry you get it
it would be a
counter a lot of times you can't because
I already pinned the foot but he got it
he lowered the center you see okay it's
from here that I do that same thing you
see he couldn't step a second time okay
uh but let's just try it without the
counter okay all right okay now we have
that dictum that we use which is uh the
only reason I'm
turning is because they're pushing so
when push turn Okay um and which is why
we're going to turn and iido you're
going to use a spiraling geometry at all
times uh which means if you reverse
engineer that UK is going to push at all
times hence our our uh prescription for
spinal displacement okay but a lot of
schools don't do that and then the
physics is wrong okay so we'll do the
same thing uh but now he's he's pu he's
going to be pushing you get it so we're
like in here in E he he's got some push
to him you see that well all all of this
that we just did it just becomes easier
okay boom just becomes easier okay but
the other one might also be easier cuz
he's pushing you see and I go like this
but you can see there's a little tint
where it got behind you see that and
people you're trying to arrest or people
that are going with your program or
don't know your chorography it's that
little quarter of the rotation
where they resist and change what's
going to happen okay which we
demonstrated statically why because the
equal and opposite line is going to you
is going to generate an angle
disturbance between your contact points
of your Bas of support okay all right so
um let us
do uh you're yeah you're there put your
static okay and I'm going to do like the
classic idag get to the back okay and
we'll have you guys
do so here we have a taller UK and
you're not pushing you just hold in
there I don't know you really like his
watch or something okay and she and he's
going to try to get to the
dock okay cool and uh let's pay
attention to
this is
he behind her shoulder yeah sort
of right
am the camera is that making sense what
I'm
saying if we if we put them on a grid
12:00
6:00 and we cut on the 93 line he's he's
got part of his body on that side of the
line you see that
okay but is that behind
her got it so you come over here here
here's her spine
line he's actually south of the spine
line okay so now let's say you were
going to do
[Music]
slowly
okay no no no T slow down you're going
to go really slow you're going to bring
her around here okay he's bringing her
around stay there and we know there's
going to be an opposite and equal energy
that's coming to what you're doing okay
and it cuts
across it cuts on the radius so every
degree of rotation that you do
eventually right here is
where it is now between
your Bas of support you see and now it's
the angle of disturbance okay so let me
in stay
there back
he's got part of him behind me but not
so he can bring me here to his Center do
you see but now as he starts to rotate
more and he's trying to bring it around
that energy right there you
see is cutting between his basic support
okay and we see this all the
time uh let's change the UK or change
the rules
okay nope go back you're just
grabbing she has to move cool all right
she got further back than him but if you
come look over
here in other words from the 12 to three
line is she that side of it yes but in
terms of
rotation this is the line that's
important do you see and and she's
not okay and so usually what happens is
your UK is going to step into it go
ahead and do 10 then UK took that step
again you see and that's
choreography and in real in real in
reality it would also be a counter it's
more of a counter okay
or you're
there and we're here you can see see
she's not on the other side of that line
here's where your Senpai UK goes
off I'm not going
go you see they just shut your Technique
down okay because you have to choose
between either getting pulled off
balance or making it obvious that you're
musling the hell out of it do you see so
you don't as the Senai nogget and they
keep going like
but for their Shan they're like they're
like going all over the place right
there're as light as a feather
all right and I don't understand how
that would ever be understood as
spiritual maturity you're obviously a
fraud okay all right so uh watch what we
do and this is why we do it okay so he
has to spinally displac you get it so he
finally displaces done it and we have
our energetic reasons for that but
there's a concentric relationship
between the energetics and the Marshall
aspects okay so I just can't get to the
back of
somebody no matter how much I enter I
can't get to the back of where the
spiral rotation is going to happen
without you passing me I just can't so
um let's do it on this side I could try
I could really try
okay but that step is not Marshall that
is dorus pal you get it that's not a
marshall stat okay so energetically we
know he's finally displacing p and we
also know
martially that he has to push for me to
turn you get it but a lot of people and
we know I'm going to turn because it's
like he I'm going to do spiral geometry
okay but a lot of people here will try
to enter and get themselves and they
consider this is the right place to be
but as you start rotating I can kind of
feel my right foot here right as I start
going it's getting weaker and weaker and
weaker it's starting to pull me off on
that opposite equal energy between my
two feet okay
so we instead obey the energetic law
which gives you to the martial law he's
finally displacing and then I bring him
around and I
enter here and now I'm where I need to
be so if you get that
Joe and you draw it over to the top and
you can see my spine is just right of
his spine camera I don't know where you
need to move to see it
okay and that
foot is on that line do you guys see
that okay so now I can do this kazushi
and if we look at the kazushi angle
let's have it over
here it is between his Bas of
supports you guys see that that's where
where his angle is so that's where he
can be taken off
out you guys see that as opposed to this
just uh pretend
okay which your your your kohai will do
for you but your Senpai won't and
definitely not your Shan they're not
going to do okay you guys get it so he
has to push I bring him around and so
that I can get to where I need to be for
spiraling kazushi that I'm going to use
okay all right so let's uh play with
those two versions no spinal
displacement and try to get to the back
don't go with it and then the second one
spinal displacement and get all the way
on the other side of the spine so that
you can keep that ground Vector okay all
right okay now there's a couple things
as we were obeying the scientific
principles there's a couple things
things that uh we've
learned the axis of rotation has to be a
single point can't be a twoo okay
and it's further back do do you guys see
that it's further back so for example we
just put that down point this
out we had that first example of
eoa when you're going to double pivot
you could be here and then you can he'll
choreograph that but when you're going
to single pivot it's back here it's back
here okay and if you're
doing a choreograph kazushi it looks
like I'm behind him do you see but I'm
not going to be and to be where I needed
to be I am back okay so he's deeper or
I'm deeper
in than what modern iido thinks
okay and and why don't they think it cuz
your kohai UK is going to choreograph
the past the angle of disturbance from
the equal and opposite energy okay
um because it's a concentric art while
I'm debating now the physics I have to
have a deeper axis of
rotation uh you're going to see that
concentrically it's going to also be
where I'm not vulnerable okay and so
when you get weapons that's where it's
going to come up all right so let's get
we had a question on the little set that
we did so I'll get you guys up to speed
okay so he's going to go I go back you
got to slow down so I can talk and then
he goes boom and the question was he's
going to
slow go and let's uh the question I'll
just State the question the question is
why don't I me 10 con
okay and my answer is because you can't
enter deep enough to do it okay um so
let us explain why I would say that okay
uh he did a
ski right yeah okay I'll get you go go
go okay and then he does
makos cool all right let's start looking
at the my here he's going to go and
let's
assume that did not get checked out at
all okay so my feet can't leave yet got
it and nor would I if I could nor would
I want to because he'll just track me on
the ADI show the tracking and hit boom
okay so I have to wait for the weapon to
commit you see which is last night's
video and I follow it all the way past
me and now I have a zone of sanctuary
that I can hit okay remember see there
remember yesterday if I'm here and I use
that same
footwork um you did the
Makia he goes down and I do a little one
he'll just hit me on the in movement of
the sword so I have to wait for that
thing to pass me okay so when can you ad
me after the after the Joe has passed
its point penetration that's when you
can do it otherwise you're just going to
re re uh Vector your targeting and get
me okay so let's go there here's the ski
and know my sword is here and let's look
at uh the range of the ski okay so make
sure you're in range do you feel like
you have enough could you get any more
penetration all right cool that's what
we like to see that you penetrated a
whole body so here's about where I am
okay and now I have to get to your back
so I'm going to
take again not Marshall that's my new
pivot
point and I'm not on Vector do you see
okay we'll do it
again go start sure
boom
boom I can kind of maybe get it got it
maybe you're tall maybe even if you're
taller than me you can get it but I'm
doing some weird with my inner knee
here which I don't do cuz that's hurting
okay but let's say I'm just about there
okay got it again I don't think this is
Marshall okay I think your movement has
to be quick and agile okay but let's say
someone taller could get there
okay and again someone short all right
here we go
back
out okay good your tush good boom I have
to wait I start
entering okay got it and
now I have to get that foot maneuver in
there you see let's go back rewind the
film bring your foot with you okay cool
and here's my rule when you're making up
choreography you cannot move faster than
your imagined opponent so he gets one
step I get one step he gets two steps I
get two steps okay otherwise I have to
be faster than him it's not realistic
okay so when he does his IDI step I got
one step you see and boom that's where
I'm going to
hit the duration between here
and here takes a long time you guys see
that even if I could have got here it
takes a long
time so this is what you have to worry
about I go
and you got to get all the way in your
ten Con in the time that I do that
okay so I go
one
boom boom boom but you got to get all
the way
around and even really he's taller than
me it's a long way to
get even if he swung the sword he might
cut me
right
um but what's what probably might happen
so either iuchi happens which is not a
solution or I go back the longer weapon
wins got
it okay now let's say that he goes
closer cuz I like what you're doing
which is you're staying out of the
radius of the weapon okay if you shorten
the radius you could actually be faster
right okay so first let's see if you
understand what I'm saying Bo
good you're just going to enter
here cool and this is actually how I got
into range by shortening the radius okay
and again the downside is that you move
inside the Joe to what
range the kicking range the personal
weapon range okay so as I go here
bom you're going to move
in I know it's it's not your nature
anymore okay you got you going to come
in
you can't be going y do you
see after I've gone
young you do you got that you can only
go yin to my young because after that
you're just opening up stuff so if we
look at the original form where you just
side
step
he is going y with my y okay here's in
and he's matching it and now he goes Yin
with my y he's going to cut me on the
back on the other one you see on these
other versions you're going in after my
yang has completed and that's why the
second Joe can come in or if you cut the
radius the personal weapon can come in
cuz you're Yin when I'm just waiting I'm
already reset y okay all right let me
have you play with that
okay so what to sum up what we got so
far the the axis of rotation of the
Turning movement is much deeper than
contemporary iido thinks it is okay uh
again the first thing we showed is that
if it's not it's probably because you're
going to double pivot and as you rotate
the angle of disturbance is going to cut
through your base of support and it's
only solved by choreography okay okay um
and here what we're doing is the axis of
rotation you see is too far in front uh
and because the concentric nature of the
art it's now not only physically
impossible as in the other examples it's
now not Marly viable because the yin and
the Yang trade places okay but if you
wanted to make it Marly viable you have
to find a way of having your axis of
rotation happen deeper okay and this
this is not the way the form is is is
going but this one way to do it is the
guy charges way past okay like he just
goes balls to the wall and this is just
to demonstrate that the axis of rotation
in aido is much deeper than most people
think it is okay so if we're doing it
again
slowly and we're just looking at these
rotation angles okay and I come in and I
run then you can see that the ten con is
going to work and he's going to hit me
because he can't hit me there he's got a
Tenon to get online and now he can get
me okay so we'll demonstrate it
again and you can see that it will work
okay but that is not the form
and that's kind of a dumb move I think
because he has a big knife and I don't
really want to run it people with big
knives I want to hit them from the
outside where I have my advantage does
not make sense for the Joe to over
penetrate to that degree okay all right